what is up everybody welcome to another
live stream on the future Academy
Channel would it be doing something a
little different today this is a combo
let's learn something and let's watch a
person who knows what they're doing
show us exactly how they design
typefaces a little while ago a little
while ago I was sorry I was trying to
make some cool fonts and admittedly I
don't know what I'm doing right and I
produced this video with font self and
somebody reached out they're like hey
you need some help with this I can talk
to you about the craft the Design
Thinking the philosophy behind it call
that stuff and remember how I made this
font based on my handwriting and I
accidentally created a recreate version
of Comic Sans based on my handwriting
there it is
and after I finished I'm like shoot it
doesn't look like a lot like Comic Sans
well I need some help I need some help
so our next guest was on the show today
he's an help here's some things that I
know about our next guest he fell in
love with type after watching the
documentary film Helvetica so you know
he's a type geek for sure he went to
tailor University and he did a type
program at the Cooper Union intern at
the font Bureau and freelance at
BuzzFeed news NBC Universal and SME
branding where he worked out to
Ticketmaster SUNY or these are some of
the projects he's worked on at SME
branding the Kentucky Derby Manhattan
college and now he's working as an art
director at Ron Vig working on projects
such as the National Museum of women in
the arts visiting her service of New
York and Helen Keller international yet
this is some of his work but we're not
here just to talk about design in
general even though he's very good at
here's some hand lettering work he's
done and design we're here to talk about
type how to create fonts how to design
typefaces
here's some of the work he's done really
cool stuff here guys and I geeked out
over this kind of stuff I know this is
just words on a page but just when you
see somebody who knows what they're
doing they designed these letter forms
just gets me really excited
yeah so check this out
this was really plenty he designed a
typeface pace on Donald Trump's
handwriting and he called it tiny hand
it's hilarious let's look at it so this
is what I would have designed if I knew
what I was doing and so let's just not
waste any more time without further ado
let's welcome Marc Davis to the shoutout
oh hey Mark what's up hi great to be
here thanks for having me on and thanks
for taking my positive feedback on
Twitter in the best possible light I'm
really glad to be here and I'm super
excited to talk about type design cuz I
moved to New York because I just really
love fonts and I can't get them out of
my head and I also just really love
teaching people about them because
there's so much complexity to them but I
just think of this like almost invisible
impact that well done type and well
selected type can do for any design like
we're still speaking about Helvetica
which is like over 50 years old now in
like Times New Roman which was designed
you know 1927 and people you know people
know about it people have like
allegiances to typefaces it's very
emotional for people so that's totally
why it was so seductive for me and yeah
I'm just super glad to be here all right
so I want to welcome everybody who's
joining us live on YouTube who's
watching this if you want to go check
out some of his work go to designer Marc
Davis calm and if you want to check them
out on social media it's Marc fonts and
may RK fonts so check that out so I want
to get right into it I want to ask you
this question because I've been thinking
about this as a type designer this is
kind of a maybe shocking for some people
why do you prefer the revivals to the
classics and for people who don't know
that terminology there's people who go
back into time look at the original
drawings and for different reasons
during that time fonts were typefaces
were designed to fit a very commercial
purpose so they'll go back to the
designers original intent they make some
adjustments they change things for
contemporary use so you may be
surprisingly unsurprisingly prefer neue
house grotesque
versus noia
and also sharp sands display number 2
versus avant-garde and erm geometric
sands number 1 over futur my beloved
futur ax
so why tell me about this there is it's
um to me font design never really ends
hmm and there's no such thing as like a
perfect typeface and I know there are
lots of people who kind of just it's
very seductive to like read a history
book and then immediately latch on to
something that you see in this book and
like Futura like this is it was you know
Paul Renner you know in nineteen
you know 1900s and Bauhaus like it's
this epitome of a geometric sans that
hasn't been created before like what
could be better than this and so I guess
me is like a type designer I hope that
all the good stuff isn't already made
already and so also with having kind of
like a tuned I for like new ways to push
for a craftsmanship there's lots of be
talked about there actually we didn't
actually talk about this but I have a
ton of like futuro specimens that I
could show you because hmm oh it looks
like if yeah I can just show you share
with you right now if you do that here
um so let me just share my screen and go
straight into this so so yeah I just
have all these scans from what Petera
looked like way back then when it was
actually metal type and this is foundry
type that people they had individual
people cutting out little pieces of
metal by hand for every single different
type you know so thousands of different
pieces of metal that people literally
made lovingly by hand and when you look
at this in the metal it's like beautiful
like there's a 6-point fitara
that someone made and like because it's
six point it has all these small little
details about it that you can't see if
it's big and modern typefaces they most
of them have this one-size-fits-all kind
of mentality like when I think of iturra
STD by
dobe like it was designed to not
necessarily look really good at six
point but also to not look really good
at sixty point so it was designed what I
believe is after the twenty four point
master of what their metal type look
like and so they took that and they
started reviving based on a single point
size making something that would work as
good as possible and many different
point sizes but they started with a
narrow set because you don't necessarily
have the control that you know with
metal type you can you know make these
angles a lot less sharp so that a small
size like Inc can come around it and
it'll actually look sharper to small
size but then also they have tons of
control in the thirty two point size so
when I look at this it's beautiful like
some of the best versions of Helvetica
I've seen just I don't think have been
made as fonts yet mmm so when I think of
let me see here
let me just clarify the audience just
for those guys to understand the way
that typefaces were designed originally
they cut hand cut every point size and
designed it to work in that point size
so what Mark was saying is in the
smaller point sizes they make certain
design decisions so that it would aid in
the printing and reproduction of the
thing and in in modern typefaces what
happens is and just probably out of
convenience more than anything else
because now we have the technology to do
custom different cuts for each point
size right mark so here they make one
size fits all best use for everything
and so it's not perfect when it's really
really small and it's not perfect when
you scale it up to be 300 points exactly
all right continue please
and so we can hop to like here herm
geometric sans number one I like some of
their it's kind of a larger departure
from pewter and necessarily because when
I when I look at type all I do is like I
just type in different words and see how
all the different letters together
because something I've been taught is
that typography is
a beautiful group of letters not a
beautifu beautiful letters so let me try
to say that again a little bit better I
don't try to think as fonts as beautiful
letters but together they make a
beautiful group and so that's a Matthew
Carter quote who's designed lots of
typefaces I'm sure you know of but so
for this they decided to make this group
of letters like all of the A's to have a
sharp point at the top versus Butera
when you get to the bold weight it's
really it severs this point at the top
for bold sizes not a right or wrong
answer but I just kind of preferred this
sort of answer to how to have something
cohesive over a family and to go back to
what we were talking about when it comes
to optical sizes what I really enjoy
about neue Haas Grotesk which is
designed by Christian Schwartz for a
Guardian paper redesign that ended up
going a different direction but this
typeface has two optical sizes it has a
text optical size and it has a display
optical size so if you for example
compare let's say medium in the display
size to medium and the text size the
letter spacing they have spaces in be
the spaces between these letters are a
lot tighter the medium Oh someone
stopped the okay we're currently
superzoom sure you're fine doing fine
zoom fun so anyway right and I do not
sharing it yet there we go for their
Arabic no it was no it was pause somehow
so this is knowing a hostage or test
display and this is knowing a Haas
Grotesk the text weight so this is both
well you can it's both Helvetica but
this medium white one in the display
size is actually a little heavier all
the letters are a little bit closer
together
but these they've also
more decisions like how a single letter
like they have this thicker portion down
here like it's stubbier so that when you
printed at a text size Inc when it's at
a small size it pulls around something
very blunt so it will look sharper in
effect size but if you're printing it
sixty point you don't have to make that
optical compensation anymore and so like
an optical compensation which is in
graphic design but also type design is
just something that might not look super
perfect but when it's in use it works
really well mm-hmm you're talking about
ink wells - right like when you get
Zachary the ink pools into a certain
place and then it creates what the
designer intended so there's a lot of
thinking and planning and designing
around typefaces at different point
sizes sure and you write so this text
weight here has an ink well this one
doesn't need as big of a one it's it has
one a little bit but it's far less
obvious so right those are these are all
like decisions that go into optical
sizes and so when I think of neue
helvetica I think I feel like every
designers work who has been who's
contributed work to type design is all
like super critical but sometimes there
are people who are able to take an extra
amount of time and effort to make
something really perfect and work in
tons of different sizes and this is why
annoy a house protest is my favorite
version of Helvetica for example and
there are you know better revivals of
Vitara that I really appreciate that um
you know perhaps made for USA Today they
had a 2012 rebrand where they had a new
feature I cut made just for them so when
I think of like these sort of like small
but in a macro scale make a big
difference
I feel like craftsmanship in some
revivals sometimes are better than fonts
that you typically think are really good
well program are using to display this
by the way this is actually a a font
organizer that is deprecated that is by
so the guys who made sketch
um they made this font organizer back in
2010 and I've still been using it they
stopped supporting it because they
realize more people you sketch than
their font organize your font case but I
still use it just because it's super has
these tiles on it so I can and I can pin
things and I really love using it so I'm
I'm jealous I still have it
alright okay so what else do you want to
tell us about these type of cases so let
me see so what was the list we were
talking about neue Haas Grotesk we were
talking about her in geometric sans
number one we were also talking about
sharp sans I mean if we can we can go
into sharps website right now and talk
about it or we can just keep going into
like the mechanics of type and how how
type designers make decisions to make
lots of letters work really well
together well I want to talk a little
bit but your preference for the revival
of Futura what you're calling that
because that I like the tour I love you
too are actually but there's certain
part that I really don't like so I would
love for to get your expert eye on this
and kind of point out some of the
differences in why you prefer the herm
cut right and it's funny because like
research never really ends and even as
of a couple days ago I stumbled on
something that's even better than herm
and so good shows up I know exactly I'm
just like it's moving target but we're
just gonna keep going I'm gonna share
this it's a it's a PDF that actually
made comparing a version of it was a
revival of Patera made by Hoffler for
AGP back in 2003 and so that license is
with went out of HP I'm not allowed to
use it I really have it but I was able
to find these samples of it but I
haven't compared like weight by weight
and so there we can even just go through
all these small little changes between
the two of them that I think are really
engaging so for example like Lud sands I
know how to pronounce it necessarily but
so they have this J they made this
decision to deviate slightly from the
futur ax bar J those can see right here
yeah and also they've done a little bit
more to kind of normalize how these
characters work together so this Z is
slightly wider in Futura but it's
narrower and let's sans but so those
sort of changes but the drawing quality
I think of lüt sans is very beautiful
and we can zoom in over here a little
bit too you can highlight letters for us
so we can what you're looking at whole a
totally totally cool um I feel like this
this cue alright well off there really
zoom in here yeah okay good sure but
this this feels so much like a circle
when actually it has all these small
little changes in it to make it seem
consistent with other characters because
if you are able to measure this this
this vertical stroke of an e is actually
a bit thicker than this horizontal
stroke right on the e because the I
typically views things that are
horizontal as thicker than vertical
things which just has to do with the
chemistry in our eyes and how the rods
and cones in our eyes usually work but
it's all these things that are super
interesting that like if you design
something a certain way to type
designers who like really get into this
sort of thing they realize oh I have to
change this a little bit even though
technically this is Renner's geometric
sans-serif masterpiece that has to like
it was designed to look like bunches of
strokes that are the same they're
actually few of them are exactly
identical so if you take that sort of
learning from a about how these
horizontal strokes are a little bit
thinner than these vertical strokes this
the top of this o is actually a little
bit thinner than this this part over
here and these are all just more of
these optical changes that people take
for granted because because you can't
really notice like the only way we would
be able to see this if I open this up in
a font program and like just actually
measured how many units are between all
of them
but together cohesively they work really
well um I wouldn't necessarily say that
the drawing quality in terms of these
optical compensations aren't bad on
Vitara but when you start looking at
overall decisions like this top hump is
a lot closer to this bottom hump on the
B then datura light which is this is
very narrow and this is a little bit
wider I questioned that sort of thing
like what can we make it a little bit
more consistent to each other and but
these are all things that are modern
type designers trying to find modern
solutions for drawings that were made
hundreds of years ago so any person can
do a version of Vitara and they will can
all be different right but they can all
be accurate and so it always just kind
of comes down to preference and so my
preference I kind of like Lutz a little
bit better than tuturro per se so those
are those are a lot of smaller things
that comes to my eye another one that I
prefer and other people might not like
this because I really like how in lutz
sans this M right here it actually is it
has this sharp point that's like kind of
a conic for fitara
however they have this kind of clever
system that this sharp point gets a
little bit duller over time from
different weights so they have this
gradual shift that happens from the
light weight down to the down to the
heavy weight down here so right here we
get to this thing that lots of people
like about Futura how in the bold way
like there's no distracting sharp coins
coming up and down but is able to do
them gradually over many of these
different weights whereas Futura it just
kind of decides it okay I guess it fits
very heavy we should just cut these off
when a medium they're still pointy so in
this sort of system thing wearing
designers and I'm like when I'm trying
to think of a typeface to work with
flying on their logo order to go across
their website I think it makes a lot of
sense to have this sort of gradual shift
so as people are seeing this font used
out across the site in different weights
or in a logo like they all seem more
similar to one another just because of
these editorial decisions that are made
of on behalf of someone who came far
earlier but oh I'm sorry glad and then
though one other thing is I haven't even
seen someone who's made a fedora that
has optical sizes which is that thing
that we saw in that metal that that
those imprints are metal that I showed
you earlier like every letter is
different from when you are able to see
it very small to very large like they
have these small changes like how sharp
this this M can get per for example but
all these things are impacted by how big
they can be used but I've never seen a
Futura that has optical sizes because it
totally impacts how people view it and
can use it so you're talking about
perhaps needing a Texan display weight
or cut exactly so and that means like in
addition to I'm not sure what optical
sighs let sans is made for but it's
probably for something like small or
smaller so it's like twenty four point
but um if some people wanted to try out
tuturro for texts I mean a text cut
would be useful for that but if they
wanted to put it 60 point in a poster
like a display cut a Futura which super
sharp points on on the Capitals neat
which is what I usually think of as all
these incisions these points that come
together they have to be super sharp to
look really nice in a display size but
in text size you have to have them be a
lot blunter for them to have the same
sort of impact same is like seeing that
spur in the neue Haas Grotesk
a like you have to make some sort of
compensation to make things work the way
you want it to look mm-hmm okay so this
is where I'm going to geek out with you
for
little bit here because this is where I
think a lot of self-taught designers
screw this part up he talked a lot about
the weights and how our eye perceives
things and designers from from a long
time ago already figured out how we
perceive vertical strokes differently
than horizontal strokes that horizontal
things tend to fill up vertically a
little bit more so they have to be
naturally optically compensated a little
bit so when you guys are designing logos
let's say you like okay mark we don't
want to design a typeface that's fine we
don't want to geek out this far but you
can apply it in your logos like when
you're designing typefaces or I'm sorry
a word mark or even a symbol yeah then
what you think is what you know is
perfectly geometrically circular and you
look at it it's like it'll feel heavy at
the tops and the bottoms because of the
horizontal strokes so you have to cheat
those in and maybe not even perfect
circles but when you look at it you'll
feel like it's a perfect circle so
through rigorous training and probably
working under really great instructors
or mentors you start to learn and
appreciate these little differences so
everybody that's out there when you're
designing a logo please make the optical
compensation and get all over what
designers usually react to is when they
see a logo redesign like Google's mark
they start freaking out because they're
like oh I know how to fix it
yeah you and a monkey can do that
because that's just geometric you just
punch it in on a math mathematical thing
it doesn't require training or even
training your eye so mark do you have a
different opinion about this um I super
agree with the need for optical
compensations I you're right I have been
trained by people who really live
breathes and preach this is that there
was a quote that you put earlier when
you're talking about logos and I think
it applies just as well to type design
because the proof is in the pudding how
it looks how it works
so you this is like I'm quoting you from
something you said about a review about
the f1 rebrand how Lots people's like oh
I don't like this like lots of people
could have done this but is a you quote
a Michael Beirut saying that people are
judging logos thinking that there are
it's a diving competition but really
it's a swimming competition
it really comes down to how people are
able to find these solutions that work
really well over tons of circumstances
so that's even why I think that more
designers should make small size
versions of logos and large size
versions of logos we're like they're
they find these sort of you know neue
haas tests text or neue haas display
kind of compensations for like maybe
there's a tumbler in ink traps in some
of your parts of your letters because
when you print it out and like a half
inch tall it all blurs together but when
you parent it on the side it of you know
a truck it looks awesome so like those
are they're sort of these decisions that
designers need to be super conscience of
when they're like creating guidelines or
just creating logos for people but also
convincing their client that that thing
is necessary because I feel like that's
part of our craft to make sure that
things that we create can be used well
and that comes with education right so I
think what you're talking about in terms
of logos or marks is responsive logos
where you design them for different
sizes for a nap or favicon or something
that's on a building and they will look
consistently to that to the untrained
eye like they're the same but you're
making all these little tiny decisions
as a designer optical decisions and
making modifications so they feel the
same even though technically
mathematically they're different okay
all right did you want to stay on this
or did you want to move on to the next
thing yeah we can jump on to the next
thing but this has been really fun and I
love going in on Futura it's oh it's a
beautiful typeface and I totally
understand why there's such love for it
but when I see that what can't what um
progress can be made from something that
people assume is kind of like set in
stone and done it can be kind of it can
be interesting for me to try to explore
like how actually is this thing that we
all think is like perfect you know could
be improved because everything can be
perfect perfect rated or improved upon
it's you know standing on the shoulders
of giants that's why I think design and
graphic design is it's just making sure
that you're aware of
what's happened before you and improving
to make sure that's just as good as it
can be alright so some people are making
some comments here live they were saying
I Dan Daniel is saying well it's time to
redo my logo again lol this is good
because now you've learned something
you're going to change that's the whole
point right we're creating content and
bringing it on interesting guests who
are experts on what they do so that you
guys can see like oh through the eyes of
the expert that's what they see and then
you could take that and you can apply to
what you do all right let's keep geeking
out over type what else are we gonna
look at or should we talk about your
work with Timothy Luke we can talk about
that do you want to bring up yeah that's
here so I want to show some work I don't
know who Timothy Luke is but I think
you're gonna tell us so this is some of
some of the work that you guys have done
together is that right yeah sure so this
is some of the work that I did with well
I know him as Luke Sherman he's a friend
of mine we went to college together we
actually both went to Taylor University
so that there's the connection um but
what is super fun about working with
Luke is he's a very hands-on kind of
designer he always has like his own
ideas about what to make his what what
his font should look like or what his
logo should look like so if you look at
some of those Horrell core kind of
things he actually went in and created
lots of these letters like you know he
found the font that he kind of liked and
he said like hey I made a bunch of these
letters I think they're working they
could be really cool if they were done
well so he hands me things over and then
I'm able to you know do all these sort
of optical compensations doing all these
things that are locked in my brain I
like telling people so just trying to
make sure that these things are
workhorses and not just pretty designs
mm-hmm now I think before we went live I
think you have some examples of things
he would give you and then you would
turn them into something right so that
was another that was another project
that was so that Timothy Lucas of
different clients but I'm happy to show
you and so there's this
this serif with this um this stencil
serif that I worked on that I'd be I'd
be totally happy to show you about
because I have a ton of examples of how
that process kind of works so I'm gonna
go fullscreen so I can flip it between
stuff so this is kind of like an example
of a much cruder character set because
Tim that Luke gives me lots of beautiful
outlines to work with and I just have
some polishing to do this is something
that a client Commission and he then
commissioned me to make this into a
typeface so when I start looking at
something like this I see like okay cool
they have like a pretty consistent
structure going I was like let me see if
I can zoom in a little bit more this is
a kind of a pixelated thing but we can
get into more of the drawings later but
so like cool they have an interesting
idea here they have lots of these
stencil things between these letters and
of course stencil is like this sort of
like design style where you make cuts
between things so that you know if you
wanted to cut it out of one piece of
paper like holes won't fall onto the
ground there's supports that come
through the paper to make sure they're
all together but um applying this to a
serif is something that I've kind of
seen before it's a fun idea
commercial-type did a great typeface
called dalla floa pretty sure yeah and I
think it's beautiful work but it's also
fun to try to do something similar in
that vein because no good deed is left
undone so when I start to look at things
what things like this what flashes into
my head are things along the lines of
well they got a good start
there got really interested in the lower
case they didn't spend perhaps as much
time on the upper case and a big thing
that I try to do and I work on typefaces
is to make sure that I'm making a
beautiful group of letters not beautiful
letters so I start to think back to a
couple different ways that you can make
a consistent harmonious upper case and
one way to do that is make sure that
these widths of letters are working well
together
so an example that tons of people type
designers love thinking of in terms of
like harmonious letter forms is trajan
it's where times new roman' came from it
is like where we pulled sort of these
scribal script things it's something
from you know 2,000 years ago but still
beautiful these letter forms are drawn
by brush onto stone before they are
chiseled out which is why they have such
hand and stress in them and they have
these very interesting proportions in
mind when these brush and then you know
stone carvers we're thinking of them I
could you know have created this with
overlays or something but you can notice
that this o is slightly narrower than
this H but this G is almost as wide is
this o and C D G Q all of these are
circular very wide round characters but
you can see with these other characters
like e al they're very narrow they're
almost as narrows as B which is kind of
in between them because it's kind of
curved and kind of flat so what we see
her are very exaggerated proportions so
when I think of like what a client's
tastes are I'm assuming they don't want
something like this they don't want
something with the Oh being almost what
twice as wide as the a that's an
exaggeration but right still like they
it is a very beautiful old time kind of
look so when I so you can kind of think
of Times New Roman is how one might
approach like more modern character
widths so this H is almost the same with
this B and this a it's it is it's it
almost seems like the same width is eh
it's a little bit different but you can
see that there's more harmony between
these lettered forms and so at a certain
point you get this understanding that o
is actually just a little bit wider than
the H and B is just a little bit
narrower than the H and C is just a
little bit narrower
than the out so you just kind of have
memorized all these different
proportions and harmonies that clients
will eventually suspect their fonts to
look like so and that's what I started
thinking I'm from here so I'm assuming
they didn't want this to look like a
Trajan I assume they want this look more
like x or roman some of they can just
throw in a page and it will look modern
and fresh and clean with lots of these
details like the stencils and these
swashes but we need to make sure that
these bones are actually working more
well with one another mm-hmm now before
we move on I love Trajan and this is
kind of like the beginning of typeface
design right because this is 2,000 years
ago
Roman characters at least and you're
saying that the times new roman' is an
adaptation of this they're trying to
create more optical consistency so
here's the thing though I don't love
Times New Roman I know it's ubiquitous
but I love Trajan and when I need a
typeface like that I use that all within
its quark so question for you is do you
think we lose something by trying to
make everything feel consistent that's a
really good question I would definitely
say that there is tons of room for all
sorts of experimentation even if you're
just thinking with these sort of bare
bones you can kind of own it isn't a
binary it's not a yes or a No but of
course times Arun was designed for
newsprint to work at eight point in
1930s printers so it was super reduced
down made super rugged made you know
designed to work very small some say
that it was designed to be so boring
that what you read is interesting so
that's why some people don't like Times
New Roman but when you think of the job
it was created to do it would did a
great job but I like thinking of it as a
shorthand of like modernist proportions
in comparison to the capitals of Trajan
so I think times the room is beautiful
what it does I think there are typefaces
are tons more beautiful than times but
in terms of mechanics and trying to make
sure that something is performing
perhaps as well someone might like um I
like looking at things that have changed
certain proportions
and adapted certain parts for different
usages but let me circle back a little
bit more of your question is like yes
sometimes you can lose a lot in
translation because people do love
tration and it totally has a place it
has an epic look immediately as this
like and there's this thing that I like
thinking of in terms of like does a font
do work for you or do you have to use
this font to make it work
so I would think of Helvetica as
something as like you need to be a pro
at design you need to use these really
intricate detailed layouts to be able to
make sure that this is a compelling
layout because when you see how Bedok on
its own it's very boring but you can use
it very elegantly and kind of like a
Swiss Army knife like if you are able to
use it very well and you know how to use
it
like it's very very compelling Trajan on
the other hand you can put it on
something on a black background track it
out a lot um it will immediately have
this sensation this flavor to it and it
infuse spirit into the type without
having to do complex layouts or have
like some bold concept behind it it does
work a ton of work for you and I think
that's super important also when you're
thinking about display and text
typefaces text typefaces need to be
optimized to be doing things for tech
stuff and display stuff need to make
design work easy for you and that's the
reason why I know a hospital Ike display
sizes that are like super super fine so
that they draw lots of attention like
very thin weights and stuff but I think
that comes down to family planning okay
I want to summarize and then I want to
ask you a quite yeah this could get real
interesting okay all right III think
this is not controversial but you're
saying some typefaces are basically like
a blank canvas that you shape it and you
tell your story and you imbue it with
meaning and flavor and aesthetic and all
that kind of stuff
Helvetica is one of those typefaces it
was designed to be whatever it is that
you can shape in and if you don't know
what you're doing it doesn't look very
good it looks boring and people are like
I'm so over Helvetica or maybe you
haven't yet mastered how to do
beautiful layouts and communicate the
idea through a simple typeface and and
and display typeface select region they
come with their own story so you can
fight against it or you can embrace it
so there the question I have for you is
this and and I just want to bring this
up for the our entire audience that's
watching right now which is this the
more you know about the purpose and the
history of the typeface that you're
using the more likely you can make an
informed decision about how to use it
and when not to use it take for example
you talked we're talking about one of my
most beloved typefaces futur before I
like the geometric quality of it I love
that boldness to it and I don't like
those sharp corners so I almost always
just use futur bold and that's it it
doesn't make great for a text wait for
me in small point size it just doesn't
feel right to me I can't explain it but
that's how I feel about it
here's what happens though people then
use fedora condense and I think this is
an abomination this is just my because
yeah everything that's beautiful about
fedora and you changed proportions and
you think Oh Chris loves for tourists so
let's use for Torah condense it is for
this very reason I hate a lot of that
advertising for Nike because they used
for Torah condensed age it just creeps
me out like I love everything about it
and then it's like oh you guys using
fortunately yes what's your take on that
no can you can you just like summarize
that last a little bit for it I mean
definitely there are like lots of
weights that you can not necessarily
like but I think every designer is as
strong as their knowledge of what
they're using and what they're trying to
do like and that's I mean this over the
last ten years I've been slowly
squirreling away information about
Helvetica and all these typefaces like
learning typefaces by name or just like
trying to keep up with really
contemporary fresh things just because
it's what I love um but in and I feel
like that sort of knowledge is the
firepower you can use like I know there
are tons of people who haven't gotten
that far into it and I totally
understand but when I mean when I you
know I'll go back to this font organizer
had since college and I've done is I
remember literally going and retreat
with some of my classmates and they're
like why are you so why are you just
looking at all these fonts like why are
you like literally I'm just like exactly
like right now I'd be at like a retreat
we're all like trying to hang out or
something like that as a floor and then
they're just like why are you just
looking at and then something like picks
up the pewter and just like oh well
what's this I'm like well that's you
know a Nimbus sans number nine like but
I know it's nervous for you it's super
nerdy you're sure yeah I know I know a
few people will like you but yeah like
this is like tight porn for you it's
like oh let's go swimming by the lake I
got a look at how Vatika one more time
exactly but like when you're able to
learn all these things you have so much
more reason for why you do things yeah
Enzo and that's why I've learned like oh
well if I'm designing something that's
supposed to look like it's 1904 I won't
use Times New Roman because it wasn't
made yet and and so that's how like lots
of font nerds don't like looking at
movies because they got the dates the
fonts wrong or like why I saw the
imitation machine or imitation game
whatever and like why on earth at the
end of this movie where people are hurt
by Germany or something is the end
credits typeset and in which is a German
typeface right and like yes it seems
like technical but like all these sort
of things that can make your work
stronger if it comes from this lineage
of knowledge I have an idea I have an
idea for a new show for you and II type
nerds the four of you sit together and
critique movies based on the improper
use of typefaces for for cultural
insensitivity or just like this predates
this typeface and what do you guys do
you monkeys and that would be funny I
mean for like 35 people but I think I'd
be yeah for all 30 people they'd have a
great time watching this like yeah
totally but then everyone else then like
five four years ago I realized you know
I I could spend better time than getting
mad about movies or just like appreciate
what this production designer did in
probably four hours right as opposed to
like critique their newspaper so that's
the difference
to me to me now when I was in college
when I got butthurt about farts so
that's what we go in there okay okay
wait I gotta get you back to the
question though
so for yours beauty is the geometry and
so when you do the feature dancer these
oblique or italic or so like what are
you I use a different typeface that was
designed to be condensed so what's your
take on that
do you know you Glee I mean something
like I know people love yes and it's
interesting because renner made lots of
different features at the time if you've
seen I'll see if I can find it really
quickly while I talk about it which
might not be possible but Paul Renner
made like four different versions of
Futura and let me see here but and
because back then they didn't
necessarily like have this sorry I'm not
answering your question I'm gonna get
your question um right I totally get
that because like when I think if you
Tura is like this modernist Bauhaus
masterpiece made of geometry you know
looks great within this you know aligned
to the left or right because there's all
your strong horizontals like there's so
many benefits of it to it just based on
how it was but of course when you have a
runaway train and you're trying to sell
stuff and people are like Oh what if I
don't can't fit you know ten letters in
this line how can I fit you know 20
letters in this line and then like you
know whatever Bauer's like fine here's
the bold condensed to have fun right and
then so I mean I feel like that comes
into commercialism yes that's why I
don't necessarily like Futura condense
hmm but there are tons of fonts nowadays
that are designed with wigs and weights
totally 100% in mind and this is why I
think variable fonts are super
interesting like in that you can have a
single font file that can have the
equivalent of you know ninety five
weights in it and you just put some
sliders and whatever I'm getting a
little bit ahead but right right tons of
type designers who have all of these
concerns with you in mind in terms of
like Renner was thinking how can I make
a
emotionless sans-serif kind of neutral
sans-serif that is
only born of math not what my emotions
are feeling or something like that and I
think that endeavor is awesome by us
when it comes down to his concerns back
then or like well what if they want to
said 20 letters align not ten letters
align that wasn't his concern he wanted
to do something that was different than
before and more consistent than like you
know accidents grotesque which is like a
notable serif sans serif at the time so
hugely for in terms of that
craftsmanship and concept in thinking
but at the same point it wasn't thinking
about like Oh advertising they need to
fit a lot of text in a small space so
there are tons of type designers who are
thinking about those problems when
they're creating the typeface and I
think those are far more successful
designs and they think the problem when
they started okay so I haven't I have a
maybe a suggestion or idea here
something's bubble up on my head you
know the way you talk about typography
the history and their intention it's
super exciting like when I sat through a
history class it wasn't that interesting
to me but a type history class that
would be super interesting maybe this is
what you need to do for the good of the
world is to sit down and and clown a lot
talk about type in chronological order
and kind of give us a little bit the
history in the time and what they were
doing what they're facing to kind of
make us love the stories behind the
typeface something for you to think
about if you want to do will produce it
with you okay that's super fun let's
talk about it okay all right let's keep
going you know what we we need to do the
demo too so I would how much time do not
sign there yeah so how much time does it
take to for you to do a little demo for
us I can do a demo super quick let me
show it'll just be like Julia Child I
have I have one already done so we can
show kind of what how I would start and
then I can jump to the finished product
and I can do that in around 10 minutes
or so that's cool
perfect let's do that it'll dig
questions from people who are watching
then cool so I am still screen sharing
if you can see it so I had a great
client who is able to
reduce and get characters ready for me
kind of all at the same time so what he
did is he just so let me see if I can
find it so there's no real fast
shortcuts so for this it might not be
super fun to watch but so what he's done
is he set up every font as its own layer
and so not many people know about this
is that illustrator actually has a
Cartesian coordinate plane and wow what
is that okay so basically there are
number systems about where things are no
stairs or artboards and so you can buy
an that transform panel but where that
gets to later is that um when you paste
something into a font program so for
example I did have like just a is an
example like it has to paste in the
middle of it so anyway that's why all
these fonts are all these font letters
are laid out on top of each other and
stuff so anyway let me start with so the
artboard is that square this is the this
is the artboard I have the background
set to the white not black okay and you
pull the inter line you pull the base
line you pull the overshoot lines they
he pulled those in well I actually I
know I might've put those in you're
right right but they're there I just
want to explain Jeremy what things are
totally right but so but this is just
simple file prep of how someone else
hands me something and so that I kind of
have something in mind so what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna copy this and paste
this into the easiest font design
program I have ever used this is what I
taught myself with in college and I
cannot praise glyphs app enough there's
a 50-buck version and there's a 300
dollar version most people will probably
be fine with this 50 buck one and
there's a 30-day trial what's the hell
what's the harm right so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna paste in kind of these
starting places of the G the capital the
capital oh wow it came it it brought all
the gridlines in and that was cute I'm
not expected
let me know Chris and may we still
tracking with me think I'm yeah
falling so far so you're copying from
illustrator in tips and it knows the
letter you have to tell it what the
letter is
oh so yeah that's a good point so um how
glyphs works is so this is kind of like
your interface it just shows you
positions for all the glyphs that you
could possibly have you can add a lot
more but it starts you with this kind of
character set that type the letter
design screen is actually the same as
like the testing screen so over here I
can just say like hi Chris and so these
are the Unicode characters that I need
to draw a letter forms into so what I've
done is I just pasted the letter G and
the letter O and I pasted it into them
and so now if I just start typing you
know whatever I only have G know so far
but that's how this font program knows
what what letters I'm working with so
like correct like you said what I've
done is I've copied the G letter into
the G letter space right pretty
intuitive so if you copy the H you paste
it into the HP so now it syncs those two
up it knows what exactly so in that it
will know exactly what I'm trying to do
as I do it so here's the H and here you
can see more of this sort of stencil
design they have this kind of idea of
like crossbars they don't actually
connect they have this sort of thorns
birthing a kind of interesting idea
mm-hmm and your money on let me just
destroy at the capital it knows it's
capital right because I in the capital H
so there's there's a lowercase as well
yeah let me get back to demoing and less
about showing so um over here so we can
see that right out of the gate these
letters don't necessarily look super
consistent with one another this G is
kind of it feels squished on this side
especially when I like try to think of
what sorry my windows are all over the
place alright let's get a crowd out here
is
back to over here so this is my this is
my my star that I'm like traveling
towards so I want to make this type face
look feel at least in terms of shaped
like how wide these letters are feel a
little bit more like times just that's
where I want to push this so if you can
see this G in this H the H is actually a
little bit narrower than the G I mean
the G is around the same width as the O
and but I was still a little bit wider
than the H though going back over here
this H is almost wider than the oh so I
mean - yes so what we need to do is
trying to make sure that these letters
are actually harmonized with one another
little bit so I guess one way to do it
like I forgot how I did it last time but
this time I'm just gonna try stretch
this out a little bit so make this H
seem a little less squished just because
I looked at the lower case and realize
that the lower case is a little bit
wider so I know that this whole upper
case has to get wider all altogether um
so now I'm actually gonna do something
that's a little that some tell type
designers and graphic designers never do
you write for now I'm just gonna try I'm
just gonna quit I'm just gonna stretch
this Gio out and then sorry Dave lose
you there no no I'm listening so the
reason why most people don't stretch
tight because you don't know what you're
doing generally speaking you could
stretch it horizontally but probably
almost always never vertically
technically what's the difference well
when you stretch it vertically the
horizontal to get thicker and it goes
off the balance where the verticals do
not get thicker so you're going against
what we know in terms of vertical and
horizontal strokes that's a very good
point
so um let me see here
at mark because I know you know what
you're doing and then there's gonna be
like 400 people are gonna start
stretching type and we're like what are
you guys doing I just need to do that
public service announcement right sure
sure station PSA really particular so
what I I'm not going to be able to get
into some of the optical Corrections I
was able to get to but usually how I
start roughing thing
is I just you know it's super similar to
illustrator I totally think this is
really close to illustrator is like I
used like just stretch things and I grab
stuff and I hold down shift and they use
my arrow keys to nudge them up and down
to get them kind of where I want them to
go mm-hmm
similar to similar to illustrators
actually like points like you can tell
that this is 250 units from the right
from the left hand side in zero units up
so if you keep looking down here you can
move this kind of up and down in y-value
changing as you move it and that's kind
of how you can keep things more
synchronizes with one another because
literally sometimes I have to go into
tight faces and be like oh this is fifty
three seventy-five like oh this is fifty
has to be like this
so you can use a lot more technical
control for control points which you can
also do an illustrator as well but it's
a lot easier to find no I can't right
now while you're working if the cap
height and the baseline are the same as
the top and the bottom of the oh mm-hmm
so it feels like it's taller than though
right right so I haven't even roughed in
the these optical compensations you're
talking about so what I'm gonna do is
try to get these nodes these control
points in a good spot and I'm going to
start roughing in that the cap height
the overshoots which is a really good
point so something that's really cool is
that I'm glyphs can do that illustrator
can't do is I can just select a point
and delete it and it keeps this and so
and you can do similar things to that
like I just changed what the value of
how this stroke kind of works but you
can also hold down option and drag this
in between the two handles which can be
really helpful if let's see over here
for example um I feel like you can hold
in also in glyphs you can hold down
spacebar and it will show the filled in
version those letters so let's say for
example I think that these shapes are
like this
hope isn't heavy enough like this this
corner is a little light and so I think
that this needs to this whole curve
needs to move down so that we're able to
have more weight in the seraphs because
you know serifs are important whatever
ya cooking chefs are important but i can
just drag these down and there's these
guides that show me when things are
consistent with one another and i just
use like these shift increments to make
sure that things are kind of consistent
along one another you can also select
things to make sure that the woods and
Heights are the same but there's lots of
different key commands that I use really
quickly to make sure that things are
looking [ __ ] and span I'm just gonna do
something real quick and then so now
just like you said
I feel like this o is with wise it's
seeming ok it compared to the H the H is
looking a little bit like just based on
like if you squint your eyes and you
look blurry I'd add a little bit you
know I'm just seeing more black over
here than over here and you can even do
other tests like down here there's this
high icon down here that you can dial up
and down how blurry it is and I think
this these sort of things are super
helpful to be able to preview what
you're doing while you do it
very handy yeah so what I'm gonna do is
delete this because I don't think I'll
need that sort of control and I'm just
gonna drag this out so that this is a
little bit lighter and it feels a little
bit closer th one of those rules that I
was taught is that the Oh like the
curved part of an O has to be a little
bit heavier than the H to be perceived
as the same way just because um well
partially because there's this empty
white space up and above and to the
corners that this character can't fill
so because of those you have to
compensate by making the oh just a
little bit heavier on the outsides so
everybody curved strokes have to be
thicker than straight strokes just
because of the nature of how they taper
off and now that you have to compensate
right but they're they're a little it
was a little too heavy so you're making
those adjustments now so like now when I
look down here these feel these feel a
little bit closer to each other so I'm
happy with that I mean some of these
curves I mean I could spend another 30
minutes unjust no just because an O is a
super important character because like a
whole third of your alphabet is based on
the curved characteristics of your row
and probably the other half is based on
your age so if I can spend a ton of time
on my own my H making them super
consistent with one another I'm happy Oh
something that I remember from type
design class which is what letters or
what word do you start off designing
first that then the whole alphabet
alphabet is built off of I think it
totally depends on the designer usually
so when I'm doing a demonstration I'm
not necessarily thinking of that because
I usually try to get my control
characters like my Oh H in my end
lowercase n and O because these are the
two most curved and straight characters
that are diametrically opposed from one
another so yeah but anyone the type
designers who are watching yes I know
this this side is a little flat deep
breath it's okay to demo relax everybody
right so yeah so I usually start with oh
wait Jenna no and my favorite character
my favorite character ever is a
specifically the lowercase a from
Helvetica it's my favorite character so
I usually like looking at that one and I
can even start pasting in what we got
from their drawings mark while you do
that I just want everybody to know in
case you're tuning in late we're talking
to Mark Davis he's a self-professed and
obviously demonstrating himself to be a
type nerd you guys can check out his
work at designer Marc Davis com to see
all the cool things he's been working on
and also follow him on social media at
Marc fonts people are asking what type
fate or what program are using he's
using a program called glyphs and
there's a free trial a 30-day trial
version you can get but he's loving his
program we're jumping back between
Illustrator
and glyphs so the original drawings were
in Illustrator that somebody gave to him
and now he's trying to make it a usable
typeface and he was also basing at the
very beginning the capital letters from
Trajan to Times New Roman and seeing
like the decisions they're making so
that he can also achieve some kind of
consistency within this design right you
know that's totally true and so
something I remember from the last time
I worked on this typeface is that they
drew the lowercase a little bit small so
I just ended up stretching them all like
scaling them all up proportionally a
little bit and then I just I think I
just bolded the uppercase so that it
would match the lowercase because most
of lowercase drawings really good the
uppercase had the most issues for me
last time so I'm still gonna be working
on some of these optical changes I think
that this h-bar was a little bit high
it's supposed to look
optically Center but not exactly Center
right for or maybe they wanted to have
the 70s deco thing of the high-waist I
just didn't like it it's done right so
let me see here um I I roughed in this a
which is a favorite lowercase character
but let's let's jump back to this Oh so
over here like you made a great point
Chris that so these optical so down here
you can see there's lots of these
metrics kind of built into how these
letters look so here you have the
baseline of the whole tight fit so the
baseline is everything that the X that
sorry that the lowercase the capitals
the numerals punctuation everything sits
on the baseline that is also an
illustrator like sometimes in the curse
you have a cursor where it's like that X
and the line it's showing you where the
baseliners come so lots of people and I
think in web development baselines
important as well over here we have the
x height so that's how tall the Capitol
is all right lowercase X is so is so
these are just actually default numbers
of what the this X ID is I thought it's
fine for right now so I'm just going
with these default metrics um and
actually let me in like two seconds
explain what these numbers are
so fonts are depending on the typeface
um they're composed of a unit grid
so let's I'm gonna keep zooming in until
maybe some of you if my stream is
actually because you know you can see it
so there's actually lots of these
squares in these dots you can align
things to in a word it's quantizing but
longer
unlike illustrator when debatin sorry um
this lets you decide kind of where your
anchor points are so that you can make
them consistent at a 12-point typeface
there are 1000 units in an inch so there
are very small changes but there are
type designers who are like oh yeah if
you move this over five this make this
serif bigger by five units it'll make a
huge difference so that's the important
of these super minor macro changes the
micro change is that you can have a
macro impact so what I'm gonna do
so so based on these metrics that were
kind of set already in terms of like
units so this is a 700 unit tall cap
height and I think that's okay depending
on your design and you might want to
change it but for this it's fine I'm now
using the scale tool which I used
viewing s and I'm just gonna prep
proportionally stretch this out a little
bit
I think the overshoot I had last time
was like around 10 units I've been told
you rule of thumb of a of an overshoot
for rounds is between 8 and 13 units
I've also heard other people say 15
units for everything is fine but I think
they're wrong good rule of thumb and you
have to make some adjustments between 8
and 13 units for an overshoot and and on
a grid of 700 that so just so you guys
can do the math right so another rule of
thumb is just based on typical spacing
should we get into side bearings
you think we should hey man you run a
dude okay cool so over here you can see
kind of built into use interface of
these letters you see these small little
numbers so this isn't tracking or
kerning we haven't gotten there yet
I'm not Kristin to have to pay me to
show you how to Kern but but what you
can do is assign these side bearings so
what side bearings are is most people
think letters are just these black egg
shapes but actually you also need a
program how much space is on the Left
around the right of it so that every
time so actually let me just quickly set
all these side bearings to zero so you
can just kind of see what happens if you
don't have side bearings so over here
everything's really tight and if this
didn't have serifs they'd literally be
touching each other so kind of a rule of
thumb is to make sure that there is
enough side bearing between characters
so that they have you typeset it like
even without kerning it looks pretty
okay there is a way to do that it seems
pretty complicated but it comes down to
the same sort of things of what we've
like learned from where's Acrobat like
what we've learned from Trajan these are
consistently space characters and you
can tell and i've also tracked these out
a little bit but you can see that let me
see here there is actually no that'd be
a difficult difficult to show from
Trajan because when it's tracked out but
I can I can just go to an idealized kind
of thing right here um if you're able to
measure there's a measurement tool that
you can just use and what you can do is
put it here so you don't have to measure
down here from where the serif needs to
the side bearing you can actually
measure over here where the stroke is
compared to the side bearing so it's a
little bit different but a rule of thumb
I've heard is that this
measurement right here is should be
around double the side bearing of a
curved character so let's just try how
that looks so according to this we have
like around 62 units between this side
bearing in this stroke and so what we're
gonna do is set this I bearing for this
out would be 30 and I'm gonna show you
probably what lots of type designers and
my shoes do they just look at a page of
OHS and ages and they try to see how
this character looks they set up a row
of H's and they see how that overall
color looks they set up a robe O's and
they see how that color looks and this
is just testing your side bearings this
is just seeing if this space that you
put on both sides of your character is
enough to separate it from the other one
consistently because it's a challenging
task you have to decide you have to come
up with numbers to make sure that you're
straight characters look good next to
each other but also your round
characters aren't too far away from each
other and then when they're together it
looks like they're accurately spaced so
let me see if I understand what you just
said they're a lot to process okay
they're totally absolutely right so the
if you measure from the edges of the
curve stroke versus the vertical stroke
he measured 30 units right right and he
said but a curve to curve it should be
half that so it should be 15 roughly I
thought what you were saying almost so
what I did is I measured from the side
bearing mm-hmm and not looking at this
serif system right because that's a
little deceptive what most of the
character is is around here so what I
did is I set this measurement of 30 and
so I set this aside bearing for the O's
to be 30 yeah measuring this distance of
where the actual stroke is compared to
the edge of the letter like the end of
its world it's around 60 units yes
double so what I did is I made half of
that is 30 so and that's one side
because I'm just comparing the
measurement of 60 units on one side that
30 units the other side right so for
demo I'm pretty happy with this we've
made when I when I'm looking down here
I could maybe make these thins
transition a little bit better so it's a
little bit more consistent but I'm
pretty happy with this so I'm gonna come
back to this page over here knowing
being pretty confident in my G and my H
that I have some set some good side
bearings so that anytime I type a know
next to another row it's always going to
look kind of okay this is where some
people get like tracking and kerning
convert confused with like letter
spacing because I haven't done any
kerning yet there's nothing I haven't
like started to like spaced out or I
haven't right so let's just make this
thirty thirty so I haven't even done
anything like making this H always go
next to the O a lot more or something
like that because people often confuse
sigh bearings with kerning and there are
two different things
so with kerning you can make an
exception so like every time I type in H
but I type a no I'd love to have this o
come in a little bit closer because I
think it's a little bit far most of the
time and you usually do that letter per
letter so like if you have an V and an A
I probably want it I mean if you can
imagine I'm just gonna go back to this
Acrobat thing over here so if you have
this V next to an a without turning
necessarily there's gonna be a ton of
space on the top right and the bottom
left between these characters just
because they're spaced out a lot so
that's something you can't do just by
doing side bearings you can do some
tricks like making a negative side
bearing for an a because 90% of the time
that you have an A it's gonna need to be
a lot closer to it because there's empty
space on the top right and top left if
an a so you can do that for side
bearings but the kerning you need to
make sure that every letter looks pretty
good
with other letters so you need to make
create exceptions yeah but in general
most skilled type designers who are good
at space
they're people who are better at spacing
and drawing and me but there there are
like if you look at the work of Matthew
Carter who made for Donna and Georgia is
spacing is incredible and I've heard it
said that ver Donna looks even pretty
good if you don't have kerning because
Matthew Carter designed the letters to
work pretty well without kerning but
even if you look at it from a laziness
perspective if you do really good letter
spacing you don't have to do as much
kerning later on and everyone knows that
kerning probably is a very intensive
task yes requiring money and exchange of
money to Hardison okay we're almost
getting near the end of our lives from
yours any other big concepts you want to
explain to us here because we got really
deep on just letter spacing there is
there any ideas you want to kind of just
point people in the right direction
sure well um there are definitely like
forums you can go to if you wanted to
have people critique your typefaces
because definitely type doesn't mean I'm
just gonna quote someone who isn't me
who said this better than I ever could
is that type designs like making
pancakes the first one will not be good
but it's important to make it's
important to make it to get to good the
good ones later and so that's why Peter
bilac and so I feel like the best way
for people to try to learn how to make
typeface is to start making them but if
you are able to you know hit the ground
running with some ideas about like
trying to look at existing typefaces and
see how they've created lots of
solutions by creating rules and
ascribing to those rules you'll be in
pretty good hands I'm gonna go ahead and
jump like Julia Child to my final ruling
of this this typeface so what I ended up
doing is right so what we have here is
okay so I did 40 and um to get inside
varies but um or any words you any words
or sentences want want Chris the future
is here no you're right the end right
yep
it looks good thanks man yeah
and yeah we can even do it in uppercase
I actually stole lots of inspiration
from Times New Roman especially like how
to make an S work well even if you take
things away from it but I think the
beauty of a well designed typeface is
being able to take lots of inspiration
from others who have walked before you
and adding your own spin to it it can be
very exciting to try to start with
something crazy you haven't seen anyone
make before but I think it's far more
critical to try to make a really well
done beautifully made sans serif or a
really well done Sarah and try to make
something almost exactly the same as
times to just learn these fundamentals
of over shoots or like learning to train
your eyes to realize that you can look
at a whole piece of paper and like look
at one tiny or something like that and
say like oh well this actually should be
a little narrower or a little darker and
I feel like that all comes from practice
but yeah so yeah I feel like so there's
a couple of questions or a comment here
where where did I get this somebody says
type there is this Christina set for a
beginner like me I find type
intimidating and this can be
intimidating because you have to really
get in there this is why there are
probably a million graphic designers and
probably a hundred really respectable
typeface designers it's it's not for
everybody but I think we can learn and
appreciate from the the kind of
attention to detail that you're putting
into the design of this typeface and and
this is why Isaac here's another PSA is
that you can imagine the weeks months
and sometimes years it takes to design a
really good complete typeface right and
I think it's a wonderful thing that
people can spend time working on their
craft and be rewarded financially for it
so I know and I'm I'm no angel here
there was a time in my past when there
was just an exchange of typefaces like
you walked round I'll give me that font
and we would exchange and now that I'm a
working professional and have been for
many years
I want to buy the fonts because I need
to support the people to do this because
otherwise there's no other way for them
to make sure and and if I can jump off
that I think there's a really great way
to start typefaces that's really easy
what's like a great beginning typeface
is like thinking of like an all
uppercase and numbers and like a period
and comma kind of typeface that is used
like almost exclusively for display or
something so you could try something a
little bit more fun and expressive
because you know you can use a caps
display face kind of anywhere but I feel
like you can start getting yourself into
trouble if you start making it a text
face because you'll find yourself
walking into walls or something after
looking at type groups for a while you
mentioned before there are type forms
when you submit your designs and people
give you critiques
Erica's asking like what's one of your
favorites one of mine is type drawers
doc um I'm pretty sure that's URL but I
there's like a lot of great people on
there who are super happy to see really
messy beginning or really good first
typefaces and they're happy to kind of
walk you this to the same sort of things
that I kind of described my first
typeface I made I did on another kind of
site called type of file which I don't
think is up right now because are
shutting down but it's the same sort of
community where you can just share like
a PDF of something that you're working
on say like hey I think this is I think
this is okay how can I improve this and
you're gonna get lots of really kind
helpful feedback I mean there's some
people who might have a different
opinion than you and then you have to
disregard them but there's gonna be some
people there who really want to help you
understand the mechanics of what you're
trying to do and there's lots of those
sort of teachers that want to help you
actualize what you're trying to do ya
know I want to say a couple things here
this was a type design that somebody
gave you and said we need your help in
making this like a usable font out of
this and if and this is kind of like a
bit of the work that you do right yeah
right so I got a couple of questions I
mean okay so people are wondering like
hey I don't like
way this letters run like where do you
draw the line between okay well this
time also that's why I made stylistic
sets I didn't show anybody but but but I
keep the essence the spirit of what the
letter forms were and making it work
within a system you're not trying to
change everything about it right right I
mean that comes to this sort of
experience of like I've made around 30
typefaces at this point I kind of have
an idea of what sort of design concepts
can be carried through or not there are
some details that I probably would never
have put in a typeface like I wouldn't
have designed a nest like this or
something and then on the other hand I
think maybe I took too much of this
typeface away like maybe this R is too
boring so there's a lot of things that
you have to like editorialize to
yourself and I think that's about any
design project but um I guess when it
comes to working with clients and like
how to show them that you're not killing
their babies I guess because like oh
like when someone hands you a tight
project and they're not necessarily a
type designer so they're not thinking
about this whole system of beautiful
words and they're thinking of like I
really like how this a looks and then I
look at that a and that a doesn't work
with anything else in the system that's
actually why I changed how this a looks
from their version I made this thing
swooped back in and I made this top a
little flatter and it looks more typical
but it's and you know I also made it
another version of the a like I revised
their version I left it in but it was my
recommendation that they go ahead with
something that's a little bit more
simplified so some of that just takes
client knowledge of how to can love how
look at this whole page of text I just
type set in this type based look at it
with this versus this I think in my
recommendation we go with this because I
think it has an even more even like that
sort of thing is kind of how I would
recommend people sell people on
different ideas mm-hmm
and if you don't mind disclosing if
somebody wanted to work with you and
they had a typeface kind of laid out
like the what you showed us earlier how
much is the cost to do something like
this I made a whole proposal for this
typeface and I had a very generous
client who is so this will be funny
because the professional type designers
will think this is a really low number
but this is what I do because I am NOT
like a I'm not a one-stop shop in terms
of font mastering like there are people
who do this professionally all the time
for font foundries that are making fonts
for Vanity Fair and the New York Times
and those people they really know their
stuff but I know enough to be dangerous
so I usually charge less than that
because I have enough knowledge but I
won't necessarily say I'm an expert in
the same level level of other people
that could be doing these sort of
projects but this project I did for
around 1200 and then we also did a an
extended scope to add more swashes and
you can see kind of nope that's not it
but can't find it but the he wanted me
to add more swash versions to the
typeface so that took another 40 hours
or like 20 hours or something and that
was an additional scope of 600 so the
final version was around 1,800 dollars
and that was kind of based on an hourly
rate but it was also based on how
time-consuming and how valuable I
thought my time was it wasn't exactly
like hours based thing it was much more
based on this is valuable to you I gave
him a higher number I gave him five
thousand for a fully exclusive typeface
which is what this is but I decided that
I he didn't necessarily think they was
worth it for that and I paddled down to
1200 and then he also gave me an
extension to it so I mean it all comes
down to the negotiation but I would say
that if this typeface wasn't as
complicated it was all uppercase it
wouldn't necessarily be that expensive
right okay so a couple things think
about here is you're taking into
consideration what this was how it might
be used as a negotiation between you and
the client in terms of like if this will
really
to somebody like it's gonna be used on a
magazine or something all the time on
the upper end of those those people who
just do just type design and for
companies and individuals what might
they charge what's at the top end of
this I just want to know the range okay
so real okay so I know for I will say an
unconfirmed fact that people who can
sometimes make typefaces bolli custom
typefaces for magazines could be
expected to charge like $20,000 okay Wow
and sometimes that includes stuff like
hinting for web which is something I
didn't have to go into because this is a
far more display Auto hint was
appropriate but some typefaces actual
hinting is required you like making sure
every letter looks really really good at
8 pixels tall yeah so there are some of
those costs going into it but that is
also a one-year exclusivity which is
mostly how font firms are able to sell
magazines typefaces is by saying hey
we'll charge you this for $20,000 but
it's one-year exclusivity if it is far
longer exclusivity that cost would be
far greater for someone that's like a
multinational client that has requires
great character support and hinting out
the wazoo and all these things
full exclusivity easily around six
hundred thousand dollars okay Wow okay
so those are pros and those are for
projects that have really high needs
okay I think those yep I think those are
absolutely necessary so let me
understand this like what if I'm like a
giant automobile manufacturer let's say
i'm GM and I need a typeface to be used
on the dashboard of all my cars and
nobody else can have this because it's a
GM typeface Jim's like I have we have
some ideas to internal designers they
give that to you you work out a price
it's gonna be probably north of 20,000
who knows but they need to own it you
can't sell it you can show it you can
share it but you can't nobody else can
use it
yep so that's the exclusivity part right
right okay and if it's on the lower end
where it's a one-year exclusive after
the
near what happens so after that when
you're usually and you can see this sort
of thing happened with commercial-type
because often their typefaces are made
for Vanity Fair like their typeface
Lejeune was made as a multi master
optical size Dido and they released it
as not VF Dido but as Liz youn so they
changed the name so they didn't need a
tray market yeah but also they added you
know the alternates that the client
didn't want necessarily I'm guessing
about that one some other stuff that
they improved since they worked with the
client so you know they can also improve
things after they realize oh yeah well
actually we can improve this a little
bit so just improvements but so I know
just a little cleanup and then they are
able to retail and release it on their
own website or sell it to a distributor
well okay so let me see if I understand
this correctly then after the year
expires they go back in and make some
changes improvements if you will they
change the name and they're allowed to
sell it because you can only copyright
the name right you can't well I mean
well you can also they could have done
the contract differently but I'm
assuming if it's a one-year exclusivity
they said you do not own this typeface
you own the usage for a single year like
so that's yeah so that's how they're
able to do it if they wanted it yeah
so if they wanted a full buyout like you
know no one can use this you we we have
to surrender the font design files to
you which I've foundries do like type
foundries will buy from type designers
fonts mm-hmm well buyout and so that's
another way because distributors want to
make money with typefaces as well so
anyway that it but so that does happen
I'm find it's more niche okay well this
has been very exciting I have to say and
I'm not just saying that because when we
started we had about 200 people watching
and and you start to get people to drift
off you really do like there's an ARCA
peak and then it starts to drift off
because once you go deep into type
la-la-land people are cool it's too much
of that other faces glaze over but
this has not happened like three there's
384 people watching life with us right
now
so mom Joan I'm just getting ready to
let you know we're wrapping up the show
here so you get fingers on either button
here
Jonah's a little slow on so so mark on
behalf of everybody that's watching and
in the team thank you for doing this
with us
I'm pretty sure there's a couple ideas
that were hatched here today that maybe
we need to follow up with you on just
who knows
apparently there are a lot of type geeks
out there you know definitely and I love
sharing my love for fonts and I
definitely love having people who are
able to rein me in and bring me along so
that's super glad you were here to help
me keep everyone abreast of my ramblings
it's been very good I think we learned a
lot of tips and we also learned how what
you do is really and there's a greater
appreciation for it so okay thank you
very much if you guys were just tuning
in for whatever reason you want to know
who the heck we've been talking to we've
been talking to Mark Davis you can find
out more about him at his website at
designer mark davis dot-com and if you
want to follow him on social media it's
at mark phonce okay and that's it that's
it on behalf of the entire team I hope
you guys have a great day that's it for
us John Aquila music don't forget to
Like comment and subscribe developer
notification everybody thanks so much
we're on this one-billion mission and
you are part of that billion mission
that's it everybody peace we're out of
here